is a is a famous editor journalist
author was editor for Scientific
American editor-in-chief for American
scientists for a number of years and
wrote a column for for them for many
years
he's written a number of books in the
area of mathematics and computation
including group theory in the bedroom
and other mathematical day versions and
foolproof and other mathematical
meditations and it's we're very pleased
to have him here as the journalist in
residence this semester maybe I should
say the the aim of the journalist in
residence program it's both for outreach
for the cylons Institute but also to
give the participants in programs
communicating their results and you know
that's it what we're gonna hear about
today is communicating computational
science right welcome thank you Peter
thanks very much and thanks to everybody
for coming to this I'm going to be
talking about some things that sound
like tricks of the trade for science
writers and might seem rather narrow I
hope to persuade you that they're not
that in fact this is all about how
people communicate with one another how
they teach and especially how they learn
applying this to myself as well as
everybody else please feel free to
interrupt with questions or having
forbid Corrections I don't mind at all
if this degenerates into a dialogue
rather than a monologue anyway to begin
with
these people are simultaneous
interpreters at the United Nations and I
first as a schoolchild this
the UN and put on the headphones and
listen to what they were doing and I was
utterly amazed by it and I still am you
have to realize that they are executing
a streaming algorithm they take in a
couple of phrases and have to produce a
translation of that before they even
hear the end of the sentence this is a
very impressive performance whether you
view it as an algorithm or as a neural
process
and I'm just full of admiration up for
them
this process has also sometimes been
proposed as a kind of analogy for what
science writers do that is my role as as
Snoopy is to listen to some deep thought
expressed in the jargon of mathematics
or some other field and then I apply a
magic function to it of some kind I
transform it into phrases of very simple
words that anybody can understand
so everything's whoops wrong button
everybody does then everything's flowing
from over here through me and then
whoops I've got the wrong slide here yes
and flowing this way
and I don't think that's actually how it
works I don't think that what that's
what I do I don't think I could do it
for that matter I don't have this magic
function that transforms gobbledygook
into plain prose what I do have is the
ability to listen to somebody and try to
figure out what they're saying and form
a mental representation of what the
whole discourse means I can't do it
one phrase at a time and I can't do it
simultaneously but if I spend a few
weeks or months or occasionally years I
can figure out what's going on over
there
and form my own model of it and
everybody else can do that too that is
over here my readers are capable of
forming their own representation of
whatever the subject is and in fact they
haven't really learned anything or
understood what I was saying until they
do so this is the key arrows here are
the ones that go up we all of us learn
not by having someone pour knowledge
into our ears but by working through
problems making mistakes trying to go
through some of the steps that the
original author did in order to write
about science I have to do that I have
to work at understanding what it's about
and my readers the point of my existence
is to try to make it easier for them but
there's no Royal Road here you you
everybody has to work and create their
own knowledge structure I'm not the only
one who ever said that Keats's version
of this has always struck me as as right
on the mark he could be talking about
mathematics that you you can read fine
things but you never filled them to the
full
so you've gone through the same steps as
the author it's not enough to just read
it you you need to do the problems at
the end of the chapter
so the question question is what can we
do to make that process less painful and
more effective and I've got three words
in the title there and this is these are
the tools that I'm going to mention
there may well be more words are kind of
the obvious choice here and I'm actually
not going to say very much about them I
mean if you ask a writer or even an on
writer what does a writer do the answer
is that you string words together one
after another and if you do your job
well you've put them in the right order
and this is all true words are the
primary medium for communicating pretty
much everything in this world but I'd
like to emphasize the other aspects of
this I think as this nonsense will
demonstrate putting the words together
is actually the lowest level aspect of
being a writer it's not how I spend most
of my time I spend much more time
learning than than writing furthermore
it's probably the part of my job that
could most easily be automated and put
me out of business what you're seeing
here is actually the the archetypal
Markov chain in 1913 when Markov first
created the the process that we now call
a Markov chain what he was dealing with
was finding the conditional
probabilities of letters
following one another in Alexander
Pushkin's poem oigan Onegin and that's
exactly what this is doing here it's
just looking at I think four grams or
maybe five grams if if Markoff had had a
computer he would have written this very
program I'm absolutely convinced of it
he had to do it by hand
so anyway words are irreplaceable but
let's move on I hope we can move on to
pictures words and pictures together in
fact this has been an aspect of written
communication going back to the
beginning of writing this one happens to
be the oliver burns edition of Euclid's
elements from the middle of the
nineteenth century it's an extremely
peculiar book but has this wonderful
device of putting words and mathematical
notation and pictures all mashed
together in the same narrative and it
works that is you can puzzle this out
and and it makes sense
I mean this is the proof of the
Pythagorean theorem or part of it it's
an art form that has not disappeared but
has been suppressed to some extent this
is even older a thousand years old from
Avicenna I'm not actually sure what
we're looking at but I think sorry I
think we have two eyes and the primary
visual cortex here although I don't read
Arabic so this is conjecture
another way of putting words and
pictures together that's very popular is
the comic book or to be more pretentious
about at the graphic novel this one is
called authored by none other than
christos papadimitriou this is Bertrand
Russell's moment of Epiphany when he
thinks about the set of all sets that
don't contain themselves I I find the
device of mingling words and pictures as
closely as we can to be actually very
attractive and wish it were I wish we
had better ways to practice it and I'm
hoping that as we move away from paper
publishing toward the web we'll get back
to it some this is an exercise in words
and pictures that actually taught me
everything I know about it this was the
first issue of Scientific American that
I contributed to you can tell how old it
is by the fact that
that the the chip there which was then
worth putting on the cover of a national
magazine is a 4 kilobyte memory anyway
we put a whole lot of emphasis on
illustrating an editor's time at that
magazine at least half and often more
than that was spent not twiddling with
words but creating pictures and you can
see in this article which is also by
christos papadimitriou that roughly 2/3
of the space is given over to pictures
rather than words however some things
been lost in that all of the
illustrations are in little rectilinear
compartments with text that accompanies
them and you you have to read the text
and then look at the illustrations
separately this has become the norm in
almost all academic publishing now I
mean you have you I'm sure all of you
know if you write a paper you have a
list of figures and they're numbered and
they get placed and in the manuscript
and the idea of being able to to have a
close dialogue between words and
pictures has become more and more
difficult
so leaving behind the words and pictures
I come to the third medium of
communication here and it's the one that
I feel is most in need of attention let
me say this is another article from not
from Scientific American that from
American scientists and this is one of
my own and we're still dealing with
pictures in boxes separate from the text
except that I've managed to sneak in a
couple of little inline illustrations
here but the one I want to talk about is
this one and this is in fact it has no
place in a printed magazine it's a
screen capture of something that's
running on a computer and it's a very
dynamic object and pasting it down on
paper and making it static is kind of
criminal because you you have a hard
time understanding what's going on there
unfortunately for paper publishing
there's no choice there's no way you can
animate it but just because it has to be
that way on paper doesn't mean that we
should have to do it when we publish
online so this in fact is the thing
itself the thing that was was captured
so
this has to do with let's make it more
fun
it has to do with braises paradox which
was mentioned in this room week or two
ago and it's a dynamic simulation of a
network that's closely related to the
one Brees described although certainly
not identical I don't actually want to
go into what this is about
and what we can learn from it I think
there is something interesting happening
here and it's worth observing but that's
another talk my real point here is that
if you want to show your readers
something of this nature something
that's dynamic it's got to be in this
format you need to present it to them in
a way that they can actually see it run
not just talk about it
I'll let that finish up
well actually I will say something about
what you were looking at what I found
interesting the very first time I
started running this is the pattern of
oscillations that these are this is the
number of vehicles of each color that
you were seeing as a function of time
and there's an obvious alternation here
when there are only the two kinds that
are on the road where you have one thing
building up and the other falling away
when you have four different roots being
traveled there's still an oscillation
it's got very complicated correlations
and anti correlations so I do think this
is worth investigating but it's not
today's topic today's topic is in fact
the easing model of ferromagnetism does
everyone know the easing model or no one
anyone I see oh yes yes quite a few
okay so I'm going to try to to go
through what I think is a plausible
attempt to explain what this thing is
about those who don't know it will be
the guinea pigs in this process of
trying to communicate something those
who do know it you can keep me honest
speak up if I'm talking nonsense
this is or began as anyway a model of
ferromagnetism the magnetism of the kind
that sticks to your refrigerator or
these whiteboards and I from childhood
have found it utterly fascinating I mean
you take these little magnets and you
try to force them together and you can't
and where you put them on the table and
and they chase each other around this is
utterly mysterious I mean the fact that
the
we're very familiar with it after a
lifetime of seeing such things shouldn't
really detract from the fact that you
know there's some in something invisible
that's nonetheless very tangible you can
feel it in your fingers and there's
nothing to see and it doesn't go away
you know it doesn't seem to require
energy and energy to maintain itself
fascinating phenomenon and so you know
how does it work where did it come from
by the end of the 19th century there was
a sort of gathering consensus about one
thing in the study of ferromagnetism and
that's that it was some kind of
collective phenomenon not that when you
magnetize a piece of iron you suddenly
create magnets in it but rather that
it's full of little magnets of some sort
and when you magnetize it what you're
doing is you're lining them up in
parallel so the the hypothesis then was
that if you have two of these small
magnets which which were soon identified
as electrons electrons would spin if you
have the spin vectors these things
parallel the energy the system is lower
than if if they're anti parallel and so
the question was if you simply start
from that hypothesis can you create can
you explain the observations of real
ferromagnets so this was we're talking
the early years of the 20th century when
quantum mechanics was just a warning and
there were some fairly wild ideas about
what might be going on in the easing
model it was recognized that the
interactions that that caused that
alignment have to be short-range and in
the model itself they simply made the
simplifying abstraction that each spin
communicates only with its nearest
neighbors along the dotted lines of this
lattice and for graphic convenience
there's no need to draw all of those
little arrows which are very hard
make out so the arrows can be either up
or down so you simply replace them by
two colors it's just a binary variable
so this is the phenomenon that the model
was meant to explain and if you take a
piece of iron and heat it up 2,000
degrees or so it loses all of its
magnetization if you then cool it at a
low rate all of a sudden it reaches a
critical temperature where it begins to
spontaneously magnetize again so you
want to explain that in terms of the
micro scale spins within the substance
and here's what what you can get for the
kind of smallest non-trivial easing
model where we take a block of four
spins arranged in a square and you can
calculate their magnetization which for
each each of these spins has effectively
two neighbors because you're only
looking vertically in horizontally not
at the diagonals and you count in
magnetization you simply count the
number of spins that are identical if
you have two and two it's zero if you
have all four it's either minus four
plus four at the same time you can
calculate the energy of these
configurations because if the neighbors
are the same color you get a negative
contribution which adds up to four of
them in this case if they're of opposite
colors in this case you've got four
pairs of neighbors that are all office
at you you get a plus one for each and
these all balance out exactly so in this
scheme we have magnetization along this
axis energy along this axis and what we
really want to know is of these sixteen
possible states for
a four-member plaque what's the
likelihood of seeing each of those and
it depends on temperature because we
have a thermal situation where you're
introducing disorder by thermal
fluctuations that can cause the spins to
flip and for a system of this size you
can calculate it exactly by hand there
are there are 16 possible configurations
you calculate their energy and and
immediately find the probability of each
state at high temperature it's pretty
flat at low temperature these these
magnetized configurations become
overwhelmingly the likeliest to see in
this case it's about one quarter each
here the the yellow line is an exact
calculation and the bars are simulation
results so all this came about starting
in 1920 Wilhelm lens in Hamburg actually
invented the model that we now call the
easing model easing was his student and
he took it up and did his dissertation
on it
is an interesting story one question has
always been how do you pronounce his
name and the answer is anyway you want
really when he was a German he was
easing he later after some hard times in
Nazi Germany he later washed up in the
US and where people called him Ising and
he didn't mind that at all and in fact
when he became a citizen he changed his
first name from Ernst to Ernest he lived
98 years to the day and I could kick
myself that I never met him he was right
there in Illinois I could have looked
him up I didn't know he was there I
didn't even know he was still living
until he wasn't
this was his publication on his
contribution to the theory of
ferromagnetism is his only publication
he as I indicated had a hard time making
a career and what he worked on was
strictly this the one-dimensional
version of the model where you just have
a line full of spins and he found that
in fact there is no phase transition
there's no magnetization and this was a
correct result it's I'm lying a little
bit here it's not quite as simple as
this but one way to think about it is
that if you have this fully magnetized
state where all the spins are parallel
and then you flip this block the half of
them you now have zero magnetization but
the only contribution to the energy is
this one pair that are now anti parallel
and if you take the limit as this chain
becomes infinitely long that's that's a
negligible energy difference the two
things are essentially the same so
there's there
no no tendency to magnetize
spontaneously and easing thought and in
fact wrote that this would this was a
flaw love the whole model that that lack
of a phase transition would also carry
through into higher dimensions and other
people disagree and ultimately showed
that it wasn't true the big push here
was by Lars Onsager whose paper I have
tried to read I don't know once a decade
for 40 years now and I have I get parts
of it it's very difficult mathematics
and kind of old-fashioned mathematics at
this point but there's no question he
did prove it he solved the model and in
the following sense that he came up with
an analytic analysis of this system in
the case where it's infinite that is in
two dimensions goes on forever it's a
square lattice and there's no external
field and dim in those conditions he was
able to basically give us a formula for
knowing anything you want to know about
the whole system in particular he he
identified the critical temperature
we're measuring temperature here in in
dimensionless terms Boltzmann's constant
is one and he showed that the the
magnetization that that curve that
looks like this is actually it's the
temperature difference from here to here
to the one eighth power I don't know of
another eighth route showing up in the
physical sciences but maybe there is
beyond two dimensions things are still
very murky there have been claims of
solutions to the three-dimensional model
as far as I can tell nobody takes them
seriously we have lots of simulation
results for it in very high dimensions
it turns out it's easy that it becomes a
meal mean field problem that you have
you're talking to so many neighbors in
in high dimensions that you can
basically just assume that everybody
feels the same average force and the
model has taken on a life of its own
this started out as a way of explaining
ferromagnets it very soon was recognized
that it's it's identical to to the
problem of understanding disorder in
metallic alloys and some kinds of fluid
phenomena it's turned up very widely
since then I'm the shelling model of
residential segregation is essentially
the easing model with people instead of
spins and there's there are well-known
applications in the neurosciences it's
gotten really to the point where the
model is not a model of anything it's
it's an object of study for itself
you don't necessarily care what it
represents it's there there are several
thousand papers on it and lots of
generalizations and specializations
where you take a different lattice or
more spins or where instead of having
the coupling between adjacent spins
always the same you
you randomly make some plus and some -
so at this point for the two-dimensional
model it seems like we're done that you
know we have an exact solution from on
Sagar we can calculate what we want you
tell me the temperature I can tell you
the magnetization or the magnetic
susceptibility for me however I am not
the least bit satisfied with this being
able to calculate is great but I want
some intuition about what this thing
looks like how it works I want I want to
be able to internalize what's going on
there and furthermore the the solution
only tells you the equilibrium State
that is if you wait long enough this is
what it's going to look like long enough
maybe eons or something it doesn't give
you any dynamics about how if you you
know if you're at zero temperature and
you suddenly turn on the blowtorch and
you raise the temperature it doesn't
doesn't give you the tools to say what's
going to change and how it's going to
evolve and I find that you know kind of
haunting that all of these people for
three or four decades who worked on this
thing spent whole careers trying to
solve it they never actually saw an
instance of an easy model I mean there
was nothing visual to go on not even a
snapshot of some state of this lattice
system it was all done strictly in their
heads this was my very first glimpse of
what an easy model might look like and
it's a curious story I I was
I was working with Ken Wilson who was
then at Cornell on this article at
Scientific American and this was one
that took a solid three months and the
easing model was a big part of the story
and he very helpfully explained much
about the analysis of it and his
computational approaches to studying it
and so I asked you know can we have a
picture of this you know what does it
look like can you show me what the
lattice looks like it had various
temperatures and he said well you know I
have no idea what it looks like I've
never seen it myself let's try to find
out and so he got he got his friend down
the hall
young debauch neck to write a program to
actually generate pictures of the things
although the pictures that that he
produced did not look like this he sent
me a box full of green bar fan-fold
paper covered with ones and zeros many
thousands of them and it was the fate of
some poor typesetter he handed the ones
and zeros and had him typed them into
these black and white characters I never
met the typesetter and he's probably
curses me and my family so anyway so not
only did I finally get a glimpse of this
but so did Ken Wilson who had been
working on it for four years and so this
is just this is high temperature
I think it's twice the critical
temperature this is slightly above and
this is at the critical temperature so
this was you know this was 1979 I think
not too much later I finally had the
wherewithal to compute the thing myself
and so this was the first easy model
that I actually computed I made a
terrible choice about how to present it
because those arrows are uninterpretable
you can't really see what you're looking
at
it's I was supposed to be the guy who
knew graphics what a mess
there's also actually a serious bug in
this program which is another talk for
another time but so 10 years later this
isn't actually the easy model it's a
variant that has more than two spin
directions of the Potts model that's why
the multi colors but we're doing the
same thing here we've got high
temperature medium and low temperature
and you you sort of learn to recognize
those things another 10 years past and
this is another one I did and I decided
I was tired of the the three panel
business so I I put a gradient
temperature gradient across this
rectangle and so we have temperature
varying continuously from high to low
across there and never been sure that
that's really kosher but I didn't hear
any complaints but my point here is that
looking at those still pictures is still
a sort of a very difficult way to get
intuition about what these things look
like because they're not still even even
if you recognize the isolated state of
the thing at a certain temperature
you're you're seeing a snapshot that
it's it's like looking at a photograph
of a horse running if if all you see is
one instant you don't really know how a
horse runs so obviously I'm going to fix
that here's here's a simulation we can
play with in a webpage so we're sort of
medium temperature will go up to high
temperature and this is not still this
is
you can see that the pattern in some
sense is persistent but if you look at
any one cell of this thing it's clearly
anything but stable go down to the
neighborhood of the critical point and
try to get the arrow this is why I
brought the mouse that's close enough
and you see what you know what Ken
Wilson was writing about in fact is that
you see fluctuations at all spatial
scales here that we're we're getting big
ones that span the entire space but the
small ones are still there as well and
this is what makes things difficult to
calculate and if you go down to the low
enough temperature you get into this
blobby regime where only the large scale
slow fluctuations persist this one
actually is it's it could go to a
completely magnetized state but it's not
going to and I'll come back to that in a
moment
so just briefly what you're looking at
here the square is actually a torus it
wraps around side to side and top to
bottom so there there are no boundaries
within the system this is obviously an
arbitrary choice you can do whatever you
want with that and the the algorithm
being used here is pickets spin at
random from anywhere within the grid if
flipping it would reduce the overall
energy do so if flipping it wouldn't
reduce the energy maybe you flip it
anyway and that's determined by this
Boltzmann weight which is says that the
higher the temperature the more likely
you are to do the flip
and the greater the energy imbalance the
less likely you are so the you know a
few minutes of looking at this tells you
a lot about what you're likely to see
the scale of the fluctuations changes
the there's also a pronounced temporal
effect in that everything slows down
when it gets cold and another aspect of
it is that what you're seeing I won't go
back at low temperature the all the
action is in the boundaries between
those two regions between red and blue
the this is where the energy is focused
it's the it's the spins along the
boundary that are in conflict over which
side they want to join and this is
directly analogous to surface tension
and has the same result in the same way
that surface tension causes droplets to
contract into spheres it turns turns
these regions into blobs and one one
result of that which we were just about
to see in the run that we were doing is
that in in the analytic model at zero
temperature this thing in variably
becomes completely magnetized it becomes
either completely red or completely blue
but in this finite model that's not the
case it's the way it works out is that
if you have if you have a row of blue
cells
right next to a row of red cells and
it's a straight line then each of these
guys has three red neighbors and is
unlikely to ever flip and at the same
time each of these guys has three blue
neighbors and so this boundary becomes
stabilized at zero temperature and you
wind up with these Mark Rothko paintings
it it only works with horizontal and
vertical if if you have a slanted line
it's not stable so after all this do we
finally understand the easing model I
mean and by understand I mean do you
have an inner representation an
intuition about how this thing works
what you're likely to see those of you
who were not familiar with this before
have I have I had any success plus one
okay I'm not going to ask any further I
feel that you know this is a huge
advance having having the technology to
put the simulation itself in the hands
of my readers or my listeners this is a
huge improvement over what it was when
we were working with ink on paper at the
same time I feel it's only like half the
battle because when I look at how I
learn
things like this in particular the
writing simulations like this where I
learn is not from running the program I
can often throw it away as soon as it's
finished
where I learn is from writing the
program from creating the simulation
from solving the problems that come up
along the way and that whole process
that's the creative part
and that kind of creativity I think is
is an essential part of learning and so
you know I have to ask can we somehow
put the reader in the position of having
access to that experience of actually
creating something something fresh in
code well to do it fully I mean
basically you have to do it yourself
that's the point I'm making and I simply
have no role in that if there there are
people out there who were sufficiently
motivated to do so but it's kind of a
tough thing to do is to say at the end
of an article if you really want to
understand what I'm talking about you
got to go do everything I did again so
this kind of next best alternative is to
provide my program in a format where
other people can dig into it change it
fiddle with it play with it break it and
that has been something I've been trying
to do for decades the problem initially
was just one of distribution I could
write at the end of an article if you're
interested in this and would like to
play with the program send me a floppy
disk and I'll mail it back to you this
actually happened I mean you know there
were a few people who sent discs and and
and a portion of those who really did
something interesting with with it and
let me know and usually had you know
gotten way beyond my level few very good
friends I met in that way but it's still
it's a tiny population who we're willing
to to go that far
now the the distribution problem has
actually been solved we have github I
mean you just put the code there and
anybody can get it quite easily
it's still a pain to try to run it or
even to install it you know I mean at
this point in the history of the world
programming is easy system
administration is a nightmare you know
I've tried to install well all right
maybe it's just me but I think there's a
lot of friction there's a big barrier to
entry if you tell somebody here's the
code all you need to do is install
Python and torch and and you're good to
go so the answer that I'm hoping to make
work is to put everything the words and
the pictures the running program and the
source code for that program and an
editor that will allow you to modify
that source code put it all into a web
page I put it into a web page I haven't
yet figured out how to put it into this
demonstration but if you click on the
link by the way these slides are
available I'll go back to put the URL up
again everything I'm playing with you
can play with so this is exactly the
same program that we were just running
does the same stuff responds in the same
way like so the difference is now you
can put the source code in front of you
and you can not only read it but you can
do things to it
for example if maybe you don't like red
and blue to political
so we can just change the colors and do
that and we've got the same thing going
but now it's yellow and brown and maybe
instead of you'd like a more cells in
the grid so
do that you get something that it's
really the same but seems to have a
different texture kind of ants crawling
over the picnic table or something and
one can do less trivial things than this
here's one that's non-trivial or less
trivial actually I'm going to first of
all go back where we were change this
from a ferromagnet into an
antiferromagnet which is exactly the
same model except that instead of the
spins wanting to be parallel they want
to be anti parallel antiferromagnets
actually exists I mean you know the real
thing not just in the model although as
far as I know they don't have a lot of
uses anyway high temperature you have to
be alert to see the difference of what's
going on here but when it gets cool you
can see that there's something very
different the stable state is not
magnetized with all red or all blue
now the batteries
it doesn't matter
it's a checkerboard everywhere but
importantly it's not the same
checkerboard everywhere because there's
a parity effect here you can have you
know read at the northwest corner or you
can have blue at the northwest corner
and the rest of it has to conform to
that and what you're seeing in fact are
again boundary regions where all the
energy is between regions of those two
phases and this also can freeze
eventually I think we're just going to
see that disappear any minute now and
you've got a stable anti ferromagnetic
state so if I trusted my typing and we
had a little more time I might show you
some more tricks but I think I should
finish how does this process work
starting point is that here that there's
really there's absolutely nothing to
install in order for people who want to
read my work to be able to just not only
read it but also play with these
programs all you need is a web browser
the programs are running on your laptop
not on my server which is important to
me and that I don't have to pay for all
this computational capacity but it's
also important I think for the people on
the other end because it means I don't
have to know who you are you don't have
to have an account you don't have to
register or anything like that the whole
thing can be free in both the economic
sense and the Liberty sense that you
know anybody can anybody any but
anywhere in the world who can get to a
website can do this stuff I did not
create all of this magic the the crucial
component that makes this possible is a
program called code mirror that is the
editor that that allows you to
can be embedded inside a webpage and
allows you to write programs or edit
programs by the other hand it's not
heaven
the only programming language available
strictly speaking to do this this way is
JavaScript which I'm fine with but not
everybody in the world loves it
the process of editing in a little panel
within a web page gets to be really a
mess when you've got a thousand line
long program so this is likely to work
best with things that can be broken down
into small bites and then there are two
really serious problems one one is that
the nature of JavaScript in a web
browser that you have no access to the
local file system which means you can
write a program to say gather statistics
about one of these things but you can't
save that the results two to your own
disk and getting around this is not
impossible but it's a bit of a mess and
finally and most seriously if you make a
mistake I have no way to help you that
is if you if you type something wrong
the program just stops working and
trying to figure out ways to at least
provide some guidance and error messages
is actually the big challenge that I'm
trying to deal with right now there are
other ways to go about this but I don't
like them this is the project that I'm
actually working on what you see is a
kind of alpha demo of what this is going
to be
it's a book-length object on the web
it's going to be full of things like
what you just saw this is kind of the
chapters that come first
we chronologically if not in the table
of contents this is all going to be
freely available on the web but don't
hold your breath because it's a big
project and I'm still in the early
stages these are some people whose work
basically convinced me that what I'm
trying to do isn't crazy and is possible
and they've done the hard work I'm
trying to adapt it and thank you all yes
they don't you know I mean why I don't
like that's a very personal thing but
they don't actually meet the criteria
Jupiter notebooks are wonderful I use
them all the time and they do allow you
to basically pick whatever language you
want at this point
however you've got to install it you
know this is easier now than it was even
a year ago but you're still you know the
reader I have in mind is someone who's
curious but not terribly adept with with
things like installing software and most
of all just you know am I sufficiently
interested to spend the hour or day or
whatever that it might take to do that
so I don't go for Jupiter for that
reason all these others are they have a
different model the computation is done
on a server somewhere and all these
three you have to pay for that is the
user has to pay for they're not
expensive Co calc I happen to think is
worth every penny that's basically the
online sage system but they don't they
don't work
for the model that I want to use I there
are some other glimmerings of projects
that would allow other languages than
JavaScript to be used in this same way
it's basically you know you write a
compiler to JavaScript and everything
that gets that goes into it then gets
passed through the compiler I don't know
whether that's you know going to be
practical
it's amazing enough that you know that a
language running within a web browser is
now nearly competitive with like C or
Fortran there it's it's amazingly
capable I never would have dreamed that
it would happen in my lifetime anybody
else
yes mom well you mentioned that at one
point in your talk that you get more
from writing the program
yes than from running it yes and that
reminded me of a quote from Dwight the
Eisenhower which I have here which says
in preparing for battle I have always
found that plans are useless but
planning is indispensable I should add
that to my list of quotations
yes then I say you have to be a
physicist to like I sing but he has a
very nice solution of two iterated
prisoner's dilemma he had a public goods
game where you you can play effect or
sit out and with the three states
playing on a grid you can play with the
parameters you get all kinds of
different you think did this no no no
I'm just saying you have to be a
physicist but the public goods
simulation is is fascinating because you
can get these societies where you can
have a lot of co-operators and you pay
the price of a few lucky defectors and
yes it's very nice to see the thing
involved yeah I I agree with you I mean
you don't have to be a physicist to love
it but but the fact is it has been
reinvented dozens of times especially in
the social sciences by people who never
heard of it you know Thomas Schelling
with his little racial segregation model
it's really it's isomorphic I'd be
curious to see what my the public cake
game simulation would look like that
would be fun let's let's do it okay you
know it's probably just a trivial change
to what we have already yes it's a great
talk just in common I think the Chinese
Bourbon was that
actually not a Chinese verb right
I had a Chinese verb verb they showed of
the proverb oh it's not a Chinese
program so it's a rhodius translation
okay and I was like those like the
Western interpretation that's I would
love to know I think the real version
yes I I'm going to be impolite enough to
tell you where I got it so that you know
it's not my fault
but it's well good sentence I suppose
but it's always been attributed to
Confucius I this is I love to be
corrected about things like this yes
yeah yeah we should we have food
[Applause]